hello and welcome to this video Klingon
last at-bat Hedgehog no information in
there about the player so probably like
Emma closed breathe I think it's correct
to do that immediately now I have to
wait for c3 hahaha ok did not did not do
anything ok maybe I can gamble for one
movie ok i think i was a bit too quick i
have to wait for this way to be played
ok now we take the pawn Wow it still
feels somewhat dangerous to me let's say
you don't have that
and just a Ponzi three-step bad
[Music]
I can just go look listen just stay
active c4s close close to being strong I
can also play like Queen to c7
threatening this let's do it see 426 f3
that looks ugly really ugly maybe there
is nothing special
[Music]
okay let's do that first and now have a
look chanda Bishop chick I can also just
double up
actually a sumo feel like I'm missing
some point here that's possible maybe
also just this yeah keep this Bishop bad
and if you go swish should be true and
rook will be misplaced on between let's
double now
[Music]
somehow that initiative is that porated
a new plug I should have some
compensation I mean I still have some
compensation but probably not enough
well maybe I have enough this Bishop is
extremely bad I just did this and play
for FMF for now I maybe shouldn't worry
that much here this is a problem for him
I don't mind to take with a pawn I can't
take with the Queen actually just I'm
threatening made only one this is better
anyway like e5 is a desirable thing to
have and currently what is he doing with
this Bishop how is he not losing this a
three maybe
and I'm taking that III i'm taking never
took the tooth bad okay here i can yeah
well as I'm taking this first ready for
between do for ya do I go clean before
here or not it's the same I'm just each
524 this is why I didn't mind to take
with the porn it's actually useful to
have the only thing is I mean he never
has to take probably when I go here he's
just sitting here how can add somehow
make him take and bring the king of
maybe i can bring the King to d6 so that
it covers a 5v5 and then I can can move
again use the Queen I mean just trading
on these three is probably not going to
go into work where is it going to a 3 no
and I go Quinn g1 that that won't work
ok I cannot take this now time morning
check
ok let's open it up
chix me and maybe get some kind of
Perpetual check check
okay okay will be difficult to try to
win
[Music]
okay okay you have to gain wrong well I
have to make the draw now I simply
didn't see a way to continue otherwise I
would have tried I mean why this
probably busted somewhere here would be
would be surprised if not it's ok the
engine is just giving me like 0.6 at
least with a low calculation deficit
doesn't see all that much ok it looks
great but maybe you cannot win did I
miss something or form so let's have a
look there you at this 26 threatening
Quincy six double attacking whether this
is not a bama we should be 50 that was
been interesting yeah I have was very
tempted by putting the book their own
tool can it's always kind of enough
compensation but also not more then
maybe I cannot win this he returned as
possible I'm pretty ok up to this point
I thing with what I did between d7 now
seems to win I'm tending to go Quinn to
be seven and then twin to be too it's a
cool idea ok and over here he got the
counter play that he probably needed now
ok a draw at the end thanks for watching